So I want you to just imagine for a second that you've been reading books your entire life, right? But you're only looking at the overall shapes of whole words.
Like just the general outline.
Yeah, exactly. Like you instantly recognize the jagged silhouette of the word apple or, you know, the blocky outline of house. Right. But then suddenly someone asks you to spell one of those words out loud or even read it backwards.
You'd be completely lost. I mean, you'd just be guessing, trying to deduce individual letters from this blurry outline that you've just memorized.
Right. And that is exactly how our most advanced artificial intelligence reads today. But for you listening right now, we are taking a deep dive into a really massive shift in how AI processes human language.
It's a fundamental change.
It really is. Today's exploration is synthesizing this fierce, ongoing academic debate across, I think, six different research papers we have here.
Yeah, six papers.
But at the center of it all is this brand new, totally paradigm-shifting paper. It was published in Nature on October 7, 2026.
Hot off the presses.
Literally. It's titled Retrofitting Language Models to Operate Over Bytes by Benjamin Minixhofer and a whole team of researchers. They're from the Allen Institute for AI, Cambridge, the University of Washington, Imperial, and LMU Munich.
And what they're proposing is this radical new technique. They call it bytefication.
Bytefication. I love that term.
It's catchy, right? But basically, it's a method that allows these state-of-the-art AI models to finally abandon their 10-year-old, deeply flawed reading habits.
And without forcing developers to spend millions of dollars and massive supercomputer time just retraining them from scratch.
Exactly. It is essentially teaching these massive neural networks the alphabet while they are already running.
Which is wild. But to truly understand why bitification is even necessary, I think we need to rewind a bit. We need to look at this invisible, highly expensive filter sitting between us and the AI.
Right. The tokenization trap.
Yes. Let's talk about the tokenization trap, because almost every large language model, what we call an LLM, reads text as subword tokens.
Yeah. And this mechanism goes way back. It dates back to a paper from 2016 by Senric, Hetto and Birch.
Oh, right.
They introduced this trick for machine translation called byte pair encoding or BPE. And the core idea there is compression.
So the AI does not see the individual letters like H-E-L-L-O.
No, not at all. The tokenizer basically scans the text, finds common combinations of letters, and assigns them a numerical ID.
So it's chunking it.
Exactly. So the AI might see one single token representing the whole chunk, hello, or maybe two tokens representing hell and low.
So the AI is just gulping down text in these prepackaged chunks. And, you know, while that sounds efficient for the machine, the background research we looked at points out two massive costs to doing it this way.
Very high costs.
Yeah. First, there's a cognitive cost to the AI itself. We have this benchmark study from Edmund, Schmid, and Fraser called CUTE.
Oh, I love the acronyms in this field.
Right. It stands for Character Level Understanding of Tokens Evaluation.
And that cute benchmark, it perfectly illustrates the cognitive blind spot we're talking about here.
How so?
Well, it shows that while these models know how their subword tokens are spelled...
Because they've seen the training data millions of times.
Exactly. But they possess zero actual ability to manipulate the characters themselves. Like if you ask a state-of-the-art token model to count how many times the letter R appears in a specific word.
Oh, the classic strawberry test.
Yes. Or if you ask it to simply reverse a string of text, it hallucinates. It stumbles. Because those underlying letters are hidden inside that token wrapper.
It only sees that word-shaped silhouette we talked about earlier.
Precisely.
But the second cost is where this gets intensely frustrating, I think, because there is a severe financial penalty attached to this system. We have another background paper by Ahiya and colleagues that analyzed the OpenAI API.
And they looked across 22 typologically diverse languages,
right? Yeah, 22 languages. And it turns out tokenizers are incredibly biased.
Well, yeah, because they were trained predominantly on English and Latin scripts. So because of that, they're highly optimized to find efficient chunks in English.
Right, but when you move outside that narrow window...
The system totally falls apart.
They call this over-fragmentation.
Over-fragmentation.
Okay, so give us an example.
So if you type a standard sentence in English, the tokenizer might elegantly package it into, say, 10 tokens. OK. But if you input the exact same meaning in Telugu or Amharic, the tokenizer doesn't recognize the patterns. It
panics, basically, and shreds the text into dozens of tiny, inefficient fragments.
Wow. And since commercial AI vendors charge users per token, the math becomes incredibly unfair.
It's a huge disparity.
The paper points out that speakers of non-English languages are paying up to five times more money for the exact same amount of information. Five times more.
And they often get worse results, too.
Wait, really? Why worse?
Because those extra tokens clog up the model's working memory. It has a limited context window, so taking up more tokens means less actual information fits in.
Oh, that makes total sense. So, okay, if we know tokenization is financially unfair on a global scale and it fundamentally blinds the AI to basic spelling, why hasn't the industry already swapped to feeding these models raw text? Like, why not just use the
underlying bytes?
And that brings us right to the central diagnosis of the new Nature paper. Byte-level models, meaning models that read raw UTF-8 bytes, they have been the theoretical holy grail for years. Right.
And just to clarify for everyone listening, a UTF-8 byte is basically the fundamental digital building block of text, right?
Yeah, exactly. A simple Latin letter might be one byte, while a complex character in another language might be three or four bytes. But reading bytes means reading the raw digital DNA of the text.
So why aren't we using them?
Well, nobody uses them commercially because every time researchers try to build one, they attempt to train it from scratch.
They just throw out everything and start with a blank slate.
Yes. The problem is that subword token models are a moving target. They are improving at breakneck speed. The data sets are constantly getting refined. The training techniques get better.
So by the time you teach a new model how to read letter by letter...
Right, which takes an immense amount of computational power and time. By the time that expensive training is finished, the token-based models have already sprinted another mile down the track.
Ah, I see.
The from-scratch-byte models just cannot catch up to the state of the art.
Which means researchers have basically been fighting a losing battle.
Exactly.
So the Nature paper's solution is to stop trying to build a brand new bite-reading car from scratch. Instead, they propose a retrofit.
Yes, retrofitting.
You take an already brilliant, fully trained subword model and surgically alter it to read raw UTF-8 bytes.
And the resource efficiency of this retrofitting is just staggering. The authors demonstrate that they can execute this transition using less than 1% of a normal pre-training compute budget.
Wait, less than 1%?
Less than 1%. They only need to feed it 49.1 billion tokens to make the switch.
That is absolute pennies in the world of frontier AI training. I mean, usually we're talking trillions of tokens.
Exactly. And they didn't just propose the theory, right? They proved it by building a whole suite of models.
Oh, yeah. Let's walk through those.
So they created BOMO 7B and BOMO 1B, which they retrofitted from the existing OMO 3 and OMO 2 models.
Okay.
Then they built BUEN 8B by bitifying QUEN 3 8B. And they made BLAMA 8B from LAMA 3 8B.
So they're taking some of the most capable open source models in the world and teaching them an entirely new way to read.
Yeah. And just for context, when we say 7B or 8B, we are talking about billions of parameters.
Right. The internal connections.
Yeah. The synapses of the AI, basically. A 7 billion parameter model is a highly capable system that can actually run on a good laptop, which makes it the perfect proving ground for this technology.
Okay, but I want to push back on the core premise here for a second.
Sure.
Because a retrofit usually implies a compromise. Like if I rip the transmission out of a classic car and put a modern one in, the chassis is still old, right? Right. So how does slapping a new byte reading interface onto a brain that was originally trained to think in subword
tokens actually make it better? Doesn't that main brain still expect those prepackaged chunks?
That is the exact engineering hurdle they had to clear.
Okay.
And to understand how they avoided that compromise, we have to look at the architecture. They designed what they call a latent tokenizer language model pipeline.
Latent tokenizer language model pipeline.
Yeah.
Sounds very dense.
It does, but it's actually a highly logical relay race.
Okay, so walk me through the relay. If the raw text comes in as individual bytes, we need something at the front door to sweep them up and organize them. I'm assuming that's the first step.
Yep, that is the local encoder. So raw bytes stream into this small neural network built using MLSTM layers.
MLSTM.
Yeah, stands for Matrix Long Short Term Memory. Traditional architectures often really struggle with very long sequences of single letters because they lose track of the context.
That's too much granular detail.
Exactly. But MLSTM processes data sequentially while using matrix math to keep parallel tracks of memory. So it's incredibly fast and efficient at reading long, continuous streams of raw bytes without losing the plot.
Okay, so the MLSTM reads the individual letters, but the giant pre-trained brain in the middle still expects chunks. So there must be a middleman translating the letters into chunks.
Yes.
Okay.
That middleman is called the boundary predictor.
Boundary predictor. Got it.
Its entire job is to look at the bytes the MLSTM just read and decide where to draw a line.
Like grouping them.
Exactly. Grouping those bytes into what they call a patch. And once grouped, that patch is mathematically compressed into a single dense representation.
Okay.
And that representation is what gets handed off to the original massive transformer model, the pre-trained global brain.
I see.
So the global brain does the heavy complex reasoning on those patches and then hands its deep thoughts to a local decoder, which unpacks the concepts back into individual bytes for the user to read.
Okay. That makes sense. But the paper dwells on a massive obstacle regarding that boundary predictor, right? They call it the look-ahead problem.
Ah, yes. The look-ahead problem.
Because traditional tokenizers are separate software programs that process the whole document before the AI even turns on. So they have this ultimate unfair advantage. They can peek into the future.
Exactly. The tokenizers cheat. Like if a traditional tokenizer sees the letters WOR, it can look ahead to see if the next letters are LD, to form world, or maybe ST, to form worst.
Right. And
it decides how to package the token based on that future knowledge. But a byte model is operating in real time, strictly left to right.
So it sees W-O-R and has to guess right then and there if it should draw a boundary.
It's flying blind.
So how did the researchers fix that?
They gave their new boundary predictor exactly one byte of look ahead during processing.
Just one byte?
Just one. It is allowed to peek exactly one single letter into the future before making its decision. And on the output side, when the model is generating text, they introduced a special boundary symbol, basically an invisible tag.
This explicitly tells the decoder exactly when a patch is supposed to end, which removes the guesswork entirely.
Wow. That is a remarkably elegant mechanical fix.
It really is.
But we still have the training problem. Like you have this Frankenstein setup now, right? A brand new MLSTM encoder at the front, a new decoder at the back, and a frozen pre-trained subword brain in the middle. How do you teach them to talk to each other without
breaking the original brain?
So they engineered a highly specific two-stage training process. In stage one, they put the giant global brain on ice. They freeze its weights so it cannot change or learn anything. They only train the new small bite components
at the front and back. And the sole objective of stage one is to force the new byte components to perfectly mimic the output of the old token system. So stage one is essentially putting the new eyes into a flight simulator.
Yes.
You freeze the main engine and you force the new byte readers to practice seeing the world exactly how the old tokenizer used to see it. You make it mimic the old routine perfectly before you trust it to fly the plane.
That flight simulator analogy is spot on.
And the reason that simulator is absolutely necessary is because of the model's latent space.
The latent space.
Yeah. It's the abstract multidimensional map where the AI organizes all its concepts. If you just rip out the tokenizer mid-flight and start feeding the brain raw byte signals, that latent space completely collapses.
It just becomes garbage in, garbage out.
Exactly. And the authors proved this through ablation studies.
Okay, just to clarify for everyone, an ablation study is when researchers test a system by ripping out one specific component to see if the machine crashes, right?
Yes, exactly. They tried skipping stage one, and the models, especially the smaller one billion parameter ones, they failed spectacularly.
Wow.
Yeah. The flight simulator stage aligns the new byte readers with the old brain's existing map. And once that alignment is locked in, they move to stage two.
Where they unfreeze everything.
Right. They open up the global model and train the entire system together end to end. This is where the model stops just mimicking tokens and actually learns how to leverage fine-grained byte level information.
Okay, so we know the mechanics of the flight simulator, but we need to see how the plane actually flies in the real world. Let's look at the scorecard, because the numbers Meenix-Hoffer's team published are pretty striking.
They really are.
We are looking to see if bitification truly allows these models to catch up to the state-of-the-art token models.
And the performance retention is undeniable.
Let's examine the 7 billion parameter suite. Buen, the Bitified Quen model, scares a 69.8 on their benchmark suite. Okay. The original token-based QM3 scored 70.3. So 69.8 versus 70.3. That is statistically a tie. It is.
And Bulmo actually outperformed its parent. Bulmo hit 62.5, which edges out the original Ulmo 3's 62.3.
Which becomes incredibly significant when you compare those numbers to older byte models that were trained from scratch.
Right, the ones that took forever to train.
Yeah. Those from scratch models like Meta's BLT7B or a model called Evabyte, they are struggling way down in the 40s on these exact same tests. BLT7B scored 48.9. Wow. Evabyte scored
45.7. So
retrofitting isn't just slightly better than from scratch training. It is a totally different weight class.
A completely different league.
What about that cognitive cost we discussed earlier, the Qt benchmark, where the token models couldn't spell or reverse words?
The character understanding score is just skyrocket. For the Quen pair, the Qt score leaps from 66.9 for the token model all the way up to 87.2 for the Bitified version.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, from 66 to 87. Yeah, the retrofit gives it a fundamental grasp of the alphabet.
That is a massive win. But, you know, to be objective, we do have to look at where this retrofitting stumbles. The authors are remarkably transparent about the losses.
They are, particularly in logic-heavy tasks like math and coding.
Yeah, the pass at one scores drop significantly.
Right. So PassIt 1 measures the model's ability to get a math or code problem completely correct on its very first attempt. On a benchmark called GSM 8K, which tests grade school level math word problems, the QUEN model falls from
84.7 down to 76.7 after bitification.
It's a noticeable drop. But I noticed a strange anomaly in the data regarding code generation.
Oh, the PassIt 16 metric.
Yes, while the pass at 1 score drops, the pass at 16 score actually rises, meaning if you give the bytefied model 16 attempts to generate the right code, it is more likely to succeed than the original token model.
It's a fascinating quirk.
Right, because if it gets worse on the first try, but better if you let it guess 16 times, is it just throwing spaghetti at the wall to see what sticks? Does it actually understand code better?
Well, the authors themselves acknowledge this anomaly. They hypothesize it's driven by sampling diversity rather than a sudden leap in core intelligence.
Sampling diversity. So what does that look like in practice?
Because byte models operate at a much finer letter-by-letter granularity. Every time you ask it to generate code, it takes slightly different micropaths.
Oh, I see.
So when you give it 16 tries, it explores a vastly wider space of possible syntax than a rigid token model would. So it's spaghetti covers much more of the wall, increasing the odds that one of those variations is mathematically correct.
That makes a lot of sense. Now, we have to discuss the hidden efficiency gains here because the paper highlights something called the softmax wall.
The softmax wall. This is a big deal for developers.
Yeah, explain that for us.
So the softmax wall is a hard mathematical limit that subword models eventually hit. When a token model generates text, it doesn't just pick a word. It calculates the probability for every single token in its vocabulary to decide which one
comes next.
Right.
And that calculation uses a mathematical function called softmax.
So if a model has a vocabulary of 100,000 different tokens, it has to run 100,000 probability calculations for every single chunk of text it spits out.
Precisely. And as developers try to make token models more globally efficient by expanding their vocabularies, pushing from 100,000 up to 400,000 tokens, the computational cost of just running that softmax calculation becomes a massive bottleneck.
That is the wall.
That's the wall. But byte models bypass this completely. Their entire vocabulary is just the base 256 bytes or, well, 512 in the specific implementation of this paper.
Because it's just calculating the probability of the next single byte, not a dictionary of 400,000 words.
Exactly.
That means you can stretch out the amount of data you process per patch almost infinitely to gain efficiency without ever hitting that probability bottleneck.
It theoretically allows for unbounded increases in processing efficiency.
Which is huge.
It is. And that efficiency pairs with one more post-training discovery the authors made that feels, honestly, almost like science fiction.
Yes, they call it task arithmetic. This was the most surprising part of the paper for me. How does this actually work?
Think of it like mapping muscle memory. The researchers took a base version of their Balmo byte model. then they looked at an entirely different model, an Ulmo 3 checkpoint that had been specially trained or instruction tuned to be helpful and
follow chat instructions.
Okay.
They extracted the mathematical weight differences from that instruction tuned token model.
So they basically isolated the exact math that represented knowing how to follow instructions.
Yes. And they simply performed vector addition. They mapped those mathematical weight differences directly onto the bitified Balmo model.
Just added them together. Yep.
Zero extra training, no new data fed in, and Balmo's score on a benchmark that tests instruction following, the IFeval benchmark, jumped by 36 points instantly.
Wow. So the entire ecosystem of upgrades, safety fine-tuning, and specialized behaviors built for the old token models can just be mathematically translated over to the new byte models.
Exactly. It's totally portable.
That completely undercuts the argument that switching to bytes means starting the industry over from zero.
It really does.
Which brings us perfectly to the academic friction here, because not all scientists agree that this retrofitting approach is the future, right? There are fierce rivalries over the correct way to build these systems.
Oh, absolutely. The academic debate is heavily documented in our background sources. For instance, we have to look at Meta's BLT, the Byte Latent Transformer by Pagnoni and colleagues.
Right. We mentioned that one earlier.
Yeah. That paper aggressively claimed that Byte models already match token models at scale, but they used a different mechanism called entropy-based patches.
How is that different from what Minix-Hoffer did?
So with entropy-based patches, the model groups bytes dynamically, based on how predictable the text is, rather than relying on the old BPE rules.
Okay, but Minix Hoffer's Nature paper directly challenges Meta's conclusion, right?
They do. They found that in their specific bitification setting, sticking to the old BPE-based merges actually performed better than the entropy merges.
Interesting.
And they point out very clearly that Meta's BLT7B model trails far behind their retrofitted Bulmo and Buen models on the leaderboards.
And on the other side of the debate, there's the HNet paper by Huang, Wang, and Gu.
Right, the from-scratch purists.
Yeah. They argue that a from scratch byte model absolutely does beat a BPE token model, provided you strictly match the amount of compute used to train both from the very beginning.
But the Nature authors retort that compute matched from scratch is entirely the wrong battlefield.
Because it's a hypothetical argument, right?
Exactly.
It ignores the massive real-world advantage of retrofitting.
Exactly. I mean, why would a company spend a billion dollars training a new byte model from scratch when they can retrofit an existing state-of-the-art token model for a fraction of the cost?
It is the ultimate clash between pragmatic engineering and purist theory.
Totally.
But, you know, I want to pose a philosophical question to you regarding that purist theory.
Okay. Lay it on me.
Is retrofitting actually a crutch? Like, if we force a byte model to perfectly mimic a subword model in stage one, if we lock it in that flight simulator and demand it only view the world exactly as the old tokenizer did, aren't we
permanently trapping it in the shadow of tokenization?
That's a deep question.
Right. Like, are we preventing the AI from ever learning how to natively read bytes in a completely new, perhaps vastly superior way?
That is the essential tension of this breakthrough. Are we limiting the model's ultimate ceiling just to raise its floor today?
Exactly.
Because by forcing it to mimic subwords initially, it is highly likely we are importing some of the blind spots and biases of tokenization directly into the global model's latent space.
Which is what we're trying to escape.
True. However, stage two, where they unfreeze the whole model and train it end to end, is specifically designed to let it break out of that shell.
And we saw the Qt scores go up.
Right. The fact that the character level understanding scores jump from the 60s to the 80s suggests it is developing native byte representations, not just parroting the old tokens. But the purists who advocate for from scratch training
have a valid point. Until we build the entire brain from raw bytes from day one, we will never really know its true unconstrained potential.
That's fascinating. So bringing it all together, what does this mean for you listening right now? If the findings in this Nature paper hold up and vitification becomes the new industry standard, we are looking at a near future where the baseline costs of
artificial intelligence become drastically fairer across all global languages.
Exactly. Because we will finally stop forcing non-English text through an English-centric biased filter.
Right. A medical prompt in Telugu or a legal query in Amharic will no longer cost five times as much as a prompt in English simply because of how the software chunks the text.
The economic playing field levels out.
It also means these systems will natively process non-language data with much higher fidelity.
Oh, absolutely. Like code and biology.
Yeah. A subword model looks at a massive biological sequence like DNA or raw computer code and sees a random confusing string of nonsense tokens. But a byte model sees every individual base pair and every single keystroke.
The authors actually conclude with a very real possibility for the industry. They suggest that the next generation of massive frontier AI models might just quietly drop the tokenizer entirely.
Just skip it.
While companies might train them as subword models for 99% of the process to utilize existing infrastructure and then execute a bitification retrofit at the very last minute.
Oh, wow.
Yeah. They get to save massive resources while gaining that crucial fine-grained character understanding.
It is a massive paradigm shift hiding in plain sight, which brings me back to where we started. Imagine reading by only seeing the blurry shapes of words your whole life, and then suddenly someone hands you the alphabet.
It changes everything.
It really does. So I'll leave you with this. If artificial intelligence finally learns to read individual letters the exact same way we do, rather than just gulping down prepackaged chunks, what hidden patterns in human language will it suddenly discover?
What nuances in our poetry, the rhythm of our cadence, or the evolution of our daily slang has tokenization been blinding it to for the past 10 years? Something to think about.